ذا كاديلاك ون،
أو الوحش، أو ذا بيست،
هذه ليست أسماء مركبة فضائية،
أو صاروخ حربي،
بل لمعسكر متنقل داخل سيارة
وهي سيارة الرئيس الأمريكي
، فما هي مواصفاتها ؟
ولماذا يمنع تصنيع نسخة أخرى مثلها في العالم؟
السيارة الخاصة بالرئيس الأمريكي،
تعتبر إرثا يحصل عليه الرؤساء الأمريكان
خلال فترة حكمهم،
وهي السيارة التي ورثها ترامب عن أوباما
لكن مع بعض التحسينات
لبعض المشاكل التي واجهها أوباما،
وها هو الرئيس الحالي جو بايدن،
يرثها عن سابقيه،
لكن ما الذي يميزها عن غيرها من السيارات الفاخرة في العالم،،،
السيارة (ذا كاديلاك 1)
تبلغ قيمتها قرابة مليون ونصف المليون دولار،
سيارة سوداء تحتوي على نوافذ سوداء
تحجب الرؤية إلى داخلها من الخارج،
فيصعب تمييز من يستقلها،
السيارة من صنع  العملاق الأميركي
لصناعة السيارات "جنيرال موتورز"
وتعد واحدة ضمن أسطول من السيارات الموضوعة
رهن إشارة الرئيس الأميركي.
عندما تتضح كل مواصفاتها
فهي أقرب إلى أن تكون ثكنة عسكرية مكتملة،
فلها أبواب مصنوعة من خليط الفولاذ
فيعادل وزن الباب الواحد وزن أبواب طائرة البوينج٧٥٧،
هذا الوزن للأبواب يجعل منها لا تفتح إلا من الخارج،
وهو ما يجعل وزن  السيارة يصل ل٨ أطنان،
دائما ما تكون السيارة مجهزة بأحدث البرامج الدفاعية،
فهي مصفحة مثل المدرعات والدبابات،
و مجهزة بأسلحة تشمل بنادق حربية وقاذفات مسيلة للدموع،
وهي مضادة للرصاص والعبوات الناسفة المزروعة على الطرق،
كما أنها مضادة للأسلحة الكيماوية والهجمات الجرثومية.
عجلات السيارة مضادة للرصاص،
وأسفل هيكلها مصفح بجهاز معدني
يقئها من أي انفجار مفاجئ،
وخزان الوقود مصفح أيضا ويحتوي
على نوع معين من الرغوة التي تمنع الانفجار.
من الداخل تبدو السيارة كمجسم لبيت مصغر،
وهي مزودة بأنظمة إلكترونية،
وبنظام اتصالات مرتبط بأقمار صناعية،
ليكون الرئيس علي اتصال بالعالم الخارجي،
وعلى اتصال بالبيت الأبيض مباشرة
في حال وقوع أي حادث،
..
بينما تحتوي السيارة علي بنك دم خاص من فئة دم الرئيس،
وأنابيب تزودها بالأوكسجين لساعات،
وذلك تحسبا لتعرض الرئيس لأي إصابة،
ويتحول السائق الذي يتبع للأمن الرئاسي السري
في حال أي طارئ إلى ممرض،
لأنه  مدرب جيدا على الإسعافات الأولية،
وكيفية مواجهة الحوادث،،
كل هذه المواصفات لا توجد إلا في السيارة الخاصة بالرئيس الأمريكي،
كما يمنع بيع أي سيارة مثلها  لأي شخص
سوى مؤسسة الرئاسة الأمريكية،
لأنها تمثل سرا من أسرار الدولة الأميركية
وأمنها القومي،
ويحيط بها أربعة أشخاص في حال توقفها،
وفي حال السير يتبعها موكب سيارات كبير،
لمنع الاقتراب منها ومنع تصوير من بداخلها...
بهذا نكون قد عرفنا سر السيارة وسبب سعرها الباهظ،
واحتكارها على مؤسسة الرئاسة فقط في أمريكا،
فهي السيارة الوحش، الفريدة من نوعها،
فهل يعد صنع مثل هذه السيارات خوفا وحيطة لأمن الرئيس الأمريكي؟
أم أنها فقط للتباهي أمام الدول؟
وهل يمتلك أي رئيس أو زعيم عربي سيارة بهذه المواصفات؟....
أتمنى منكم وضع إجاباتكم في التعليقات
...